Now there is proof of this also, it is not that there is
no proof of it but then it is the same thing, why
look at it now, it will not come in the exam,
questions will come on it, sensor of date will be
question for D, best of friends topic, do
not do such things which will not come in the exams.
Look, I will tell you that you should shy away from Puri Road,
you do everything, do it romantically,
definitely do it, now is the exam time,
so the date is full marks according to the exam, it is
not that you are getting anything due due to
any carelessness.  You other region right this
video lodging respect or say
rise, put it in such a way so that he can see directly what has to be
done here, for which thing
yes and no.